now to florida where many kids went back
to school yesterday despite skyrocketing
coveted numbers cases among children and
teenagers are up nearly 400 percent in
the state from this time last year 400
percent the state's second largest
school district is now defying the
governor's ban on mass mandates and
requiring all students and teachers to
mask up manuel bajorquez has more from
miami
i'm trying to encourage everybody to
please take this delta variant very
seriously due to the transmissibility it
is incredibly contagious and our
children are getting sick
i can't do this pediatric doctor pia
myers got emotional as she recorded a
video message for the public about the
challenges in collier county florida
leads the nation in pediatric
hospitalizations with more than 300
reported in the last week children now
account for nearly 15 percent of all new
infections nationwide that's why the
american academy of pediatrics is
pushing the fda to approve the vaccine
for kids ages 5 to 11. dr yvonne
maldonado is the organization's chair of
infectious diseases do you fear what
will happen in a state like florida as
schools begin well we see what's already
happening in florida and we don't want
that to happen in schools we love
teachers protests erupted on both sides
in florida after the governor banned
schools from requiring masks and even
threatened the salaries of
superintendents and school board members
who defied him my view is it's a
parent's decision if you believe in
the masking during the school you're
free to do it but that didn't stop
broward county the state's second
largest school district for voting
tuesday to require masks
i can die if people do not have their
mask on
i don't feel comfortable with my son
having to go into school
and having to wear a mask the entire day
five days a week our educators in the
state of florida they are going to be
there for the kids as they have always
done andrew sparr is president of the
florida education association for him
it's personal his wife is a public
school teacher and his youngest daughter
is entering seventh grade i'm concerned
about my daughter who is vaccinated and
will be wearing a mask
and the fact that there will be others
who are not vaccinated and are not
wearing a mask and so we want to make
sure that everyone is safe
there is some encouraging news when it
comes to vaccinations across the country
according to the cdc the pace of first
doses is nearly double what it was 30
days ago tony could be a lesson learned
there manny thank you very much